yes Matthew McConaughey does get a scene
where he gets to take your shirt off The
Lincoln Lawyer stars Matthew McConaughey
Ryan Philippe John Leguizamo William age
Macy Marisa Tomei Josh Lucas it's a
courtroom drama and this is that's
something that's unfamiliar to Matthew
McConaughey I believe he was a lawyer in
the movie Amistad directed by Steven
Spielberg he was a lawyer and
time-to-kill I feel like I'm talking
like Matthew McConaughey now yeah it was
good actor you know he knows how to play
a lawyer he's in a lot of stupid dumb
comedies that he should stop doing but
for the most part he knows what he's
doing about the camera he's a dramatic
actor Your Honor I'm saying like sir I
just take off shirt a lot I'm very
bright anyway Ryan Phillippe has been
accused of beating almost to death this
woman who he says seduced him he says
that someone else beat her up and that
she's just setting him up to try to get
some of his money so Matthew McConaughey
has to find out the truth about this
case there's a lot of investigating with
the william h Macy who is fantastic in
this film he is such a great supporting
character
he's so fun he's so entertaining he's
just I love him he's a great actor so
basically most of the movie is Matthew
McConaughey trying to investigate
whether this guy's telling the truth or
not he has the right as a lawyer to
defend him even if he thinks he's guilty
but he still has to try to figure out a
way for justice to happen this is a
really good back-and-forth not sure
whodunit whose side are you on kind of
thriller and I really enjoyed this when
I first saw this trailer I was like it
was terrible
but you know why it's terrible you know
why the trailer looks bad it doesn't
give anything away all the best parts of
the movie are concealed in the trailer I
am so used to trailers giving away all
the best parts the funniest jokes the
coolest action shots you know the whole
movie and the one trailer and you think
wow that was a really awesome trailer
that's because they gave away all the
best
stuff in like a little 2-minute thing
this trailer has none of the secrets of
this movie
none of the best parts it's all we've
held that's where the trailer wasn't all
that great and I love that because when
I saw the movie I didn't know what was
gonna happen I didn't know anything I
couldn't guess you know things based off
of what was in the trailer so good job
on that trailer guys even though it I
didn't think was gonna be that great
Matthew McConaughey I cannot say his
name without saying Matthew McConaughey
apparently anyway he is great in this
movie he's really fun he's very
entertaining characters funny his
character's believable as a lawyer and
as a father he has a lot of emotion held
up in his character and you can tell he
cares a lot about his family
but he cares very much about his job and
justice he's not a bad lawyer he wants
everyone to get justice for the right
thing Matthew McConaughey does a really
good job here I love when he goes
serious you know he does so many stupid
romantic comedies that are just but when
he does a serious for all he's really a
very good reason this this movie
reminded me why he's in a hector
actually because he did a very good job
in this film the direction is good it's
well edited well-written dramatic scenes
all have a really good punch the
courtroom scenes are suspenseful
all-around good performances good
Direction good screenwriting some of the
cons of the film it's over long after a
while I started thinking it should have
ended a while back but it still was
always entertaining it takes a little
while for the case to get interesting
I'd say about 40 minutes into the movie
I started thinking you know this is
getting really interesting I've been to
this story but once everything starts
flowing this is a really fun really
entertaining courtroom drama I really
enjoy the Lincoln Lawyer I'm gonna give
you three out of four stars good
performance it's good Direction good
writing a very enjoyable story if you
enjoy courtroom dramas this is a good
one
you know mr. director this courtroom
scene feels kind of boring
maybe I should take off my shirt yeah
and you think I should make take my
shirt off even me that's a good idea
I guess I would be able to distracting
right I'm Matthew McConaughey
it's from Blake Kennedy you know what
you should subscribe a bit little fella
yeah I'll put a link for him grab a 47